die nervosität wächst in der nacht
stoppen österreichische behörden einen
zug aus venedig weil zwei deutsche
frauen darin mit starkem husten und
fieber symptomen aufgefallen sind
ein schnelltest im krankenhaus gibt
entwarnung erst dann darf der zug nach
münchen weiterfahren
italien hat sich in europa zum größten
wert des neuartigen corona virus
entwickelt die betroffenen städte im
norden des landes sind streng
abgeriegelt viele supermarkt regale sind
schon leer gekauft nicht nur in mailand
kommt es zu hamsterkäufen
auch im fernen rom machen sich die
menschen gedanken über den umgang mit
der krankheit
ich arbeite für eine it firma in mailand
haben sie unser büro schon geschlossen
meine kollegen müssen von zu hause
arbeiten ich selbst bin noch nicht zu
nervös aber es ist schon eine ernste
situation
eine plötzliche ausbreitung des virus
wie in italien könnte experten zufolge
auch in deutschland drohen es ist gut
möglich dass wir dieses virus schon im
land haben dass wir das gar nicht
bemerken dass es ein sehr still sich
verbreitung des virus mit sehr milden
vollkommen harmlosen symptomen bei den
meisten menschen und es fällt eben erst
dann auf wenn seltener weise mal ein
patient schwerer erkrankt wird und dann
auch getestet wird wie das jetzt in
italien der fall gewesen ist
die eu kommission begrüsst die
massnahmen die italien ergriffen hat sie
stellt 230 millionen euro für den kampf
gegen das virus zur verfügung